we are told that the cosine of 58
degrees is roughly equal to zero point
five three and that's roughly equal to
because it just keeps going on and on I
just rounded it to the nearest hundredth
and then there we're asked what is the
sine of 32 degrees and I encourage you
to pause this video and try it on your
own and a hint is to look at this right
triangle one of the angles is already
labeled 32 degrees figure out what all
of the angles are and then use the
fundamental definitions your sohcahtoa
definitions to see if you could figure
out what sine of 32 degrees is so I'm
assuming you've given a go at it let's
work on let's work it through now so we
know that the sum of the angles of a
triangle add up to 180 now in a right
angle one of the angles is 90 degrees so
that means that the other two must add
up to 99 these two add up to 90 plus
another 90 is going to be 180 degrees or
another way to think about it is that
the other two non right angles are going
to be complementary so what plus 32 is
equal to 90 well 90 minus 32 is 58 so
this right over here is going to be 58
degrees well why is that interesting
well we already know what the cosine of
58 degrees is equal to but let's think
about it in terms of ratios of the
lengths of sides of this right triangle
let's just write down sohcahtoa so sine
is opposite over hypotenuse cosine is
adjacent over hypotenuse Toa tangent is
opposite over adjacent so we could write
down the cosine of 58 degrees which we
already know if we think about it in
terms of these fundamental ratios cosine
is adjacent over hypotenuse this is the
58 degree angle the side that is
adjacent to it is let me do it in this
color is side BC right over here
it's one of the sides of the angle the
side of the angle that is not the
hypotenuse the other side this over here
is the hypotenuse so this is going to be
the adjacent the length of the adjacent
side BC over the length of the
hypotenuse over the length of the
hypotenuse the length of the hypotenuse
well that is a B now let's think about
what the sine of 32 degrees would be
so the sine of 32 degrees well sine is
opposite over hypotenuse so now we're
looking at this 32 degree angle what
side is opposite well it opens up onto
BC it opens up onto BC just like that
and what's the hypotenuse well we've
already or the length of the hypotenuse
it's a B it's a B notice the sine of 32
degrees is BC over a B the cosine of 58
degrees is BC over a B or another way of
thinking about the sine of this angle is
the same thing as the cosine of this
angle so we could literally write the
sine I want to do that in that pink
color the sine the sine of 32 degrees is
equal to the cosine cosine of 58 degrees
which is roughly equal to 0.5 3 and this
is a really really useful property the
sine of an angle is equal to the cosine
of its complement so we could write this
in general terms we could write that the
sine of some angle is equal to the
cosine of its complement is equal to the
cosine of 90 minus theta think about it
I could have done I could change change
this entire problem instead of making
this the sine of 32 degrees I could make
this the sine of 25 degrees and if
someone gave you the cosine of what's 90
minus 25 if someone gave you the cosine
of 65 degrees then you could think about
this as 25 the complement is going to be
right over here this would be 65 degrees
and then you could use the exact same
idea